hi everyone it's Jerry in 1922 Alexander
alien who's primarily known for his
dynamic style of play produced a
positional gem against Frederick Yates
the highlights of this game include a
good night versus bad Bishop imbalance
control of an only open file and a
methodical endgame squeeze with the
picturesque finish so we have a lien on
the white end opening up with d4 after
Knight f6 c4 and a six maybe going in
for an insult but it quickly transposes
after Knight f3 and d5 we have a Queens
gambit declined Bishop e7 Bishop g5 this
will be very important detail the bishop
first getting outside of the eventual
dark square pawn structure after castles
III Knight B to d7 some developing moves
on the black end and the in particular
with the white moves were having really
the delay of this light square bishop
development the rook is getting to a
file that's going to be opened at some
point these pawns will be capturing at
some point and the rook will find it
useful to be on the C file c6 is just
reinforcing that Center Queen c2 eyeing
that e4 square again not yet committing
this bishop ideally white would like to
have black capture prior to the bishop
moving but after rook to e8 vacating f8
for let's say this Knight now white is
pretty much out of useful moves to make
there's only so much delay that you can
give the deployment of this light square
bishop the rook on c1 the Queen on c2
eventually you're going to have to move
that bishop and so only after the bishop
moves does black now take on c4 and so
black gave up the center we now have a
2-1 majority in favor of white and now
black is able to pivot on this d5 square
with the main idea of basically being to
exchange some pieces since white has a
better center has some more space in the
center makes sense to want to exchange
pieces so
the reaction here is with 94 and we
pretty much have a positional blunder
and this 11th moved by black and it's
one that white just completely punishes
and we have a pretty much a positional
squeeze from here on out the reaction at
this point was f5 and before the night
even reacts to the threat we have the
exchange of lights bad bishop for blacks
good bishop and this isn't a very
important detail because now what
remains
once those bishops are stripped of the
position what remains is this bishop
being very bad we could have situations
in fact where it could turn out to be
white having a good versus bad bishop or
a good night versus a bad bishop however
you slice it for as long as this guy on
c8 is around black is going to be in
some serious trouble not to mention with
this move this last pawn ruled by black
f5 the downside with that the biggest
downside is going to be that be 5 square
something that a white knight can now
rely upon for the remainder of the game
so first off the knight is having to
react and we have Knight to d2 and the
intention here is to keep a close eye on
not only e5 this Knight has a close eye
on e5 but this night is not far off from
focusing on c5 and these these two these
five the e5 and c5 squares are key
squares and the reason why they should
be popping up in your own mind or
because these are potential pawn breaks
that black could try to get in and so it
makes sense to try and as white prevent
those advances so first Knight died on e
- d - b5 putting a question to this
bishop and this is another very
committal move earlier it was ePHI that
was weakened with the f5 move and now
with b5 we have this c5 square being
weakened these two right here incredibly
weak and
gets punished very quickly so Bishop
takes Knight this is a pretty much
closed position so the Knights are going
to be much more dominant again that
everything is really at this point
pointing to this bishop and also this
file right here which is firmly under
White's control
so first finishing development is white
castling a5 looking to gain some space
on the Queen side and now before a four
can be played to watch out for b3 the
knight makes use of that and is eyeing
c5 and it jumps right in there we have a
bunch of exchanges going on and now
we're transitioning this is clearly an
endgame this is still maintained control
over this C file good night versus
terrible Bishop and this knight that's
going to be able to post on e5 and never
be dislodged so what is tried is well
there's not much to even try on the
black side this is basically a waiting
game and kind of hoping white isn't
going to be able to make progress but
white makes quick progress of this
position first doubling rooks the bishop
gets doing something okay it's off the
back rank but it's kind of staring at a
diagonal that's not going to be of any
benefit to black-white centralizes the
knight route to b8 again these moves
that black is making pretty much for the
remainder of the game
are strictly defensive against threats
against maybe the bishop or the pawn
other than that they're just white army
black is just kind of shuffling back and
forth and there's not really a way to
neutralize the rooks influence on this
e-file with let's say simplifying this
is not going to work out if we have this
type of exchange going on at the end of
it we have the night playing to d3
threatening this pawn and after push we
could just take recapture Knight c5 this
pawn is going to be lost and this is
going to also be a one position for
white so in short you really can't do
anything about White's control
over this c-file because white would
ultimately be winning upon and that's a
significant one because it'd be a past
Potanin still even so this idea again of
good night versus bad bishop is uh
persisting okay so Brooke on II to be
eight and now F three the start of a
king walk first pivoting on F 3 B 3 is
met with a three just if you're in
control the only open file there's no
need to create other open files so just
keep things closed White has control of
that C file h6 in here we go with the
king walk King f2 King age seven h4
looking for this clamping down move with
h5 clamping down on the h6 in g7
structure broke f8 again nothing going
on to the black side more progress for
white king g3 rook b8 one Pig I'm the
seventh looking to get a second one on
there shortly Bishop b5 the rook is now
getting active putting pressure on that
Bishop Bishop goes back the rook is now
hitting at two points black is now just
defending and now we have the King
sneaking in even further on f5 black
just shuffling playing to g8 h5 clamping
down on that structure the bishop making
one move threats out in g2 g3 to meet
that threat the vicious goes back and
now white is just getting ready to
double Brooks and put pressure on g7 for
a second time and there's not really
anything that could be done if you
challenge there look like this we could
just have capture and while this pawn is
going to fall so what black is trying is
just scooting the king out of the way
preparing to meet the doubling of the
rooks which is what is played in this
game with rook to g8 to defend and now
we have really the final combination
which is really beautiful it starts out
with Knight d7 looking for a fork right
here exploiting the pin
on that g7 pond black sidesteps that but
the night goes there anyway knowing full
well that if it's taken is just a
million one on h7 so after Knight f6
rook f8 everything looks like it's been
saved on the black end or at least I
should say one pair of rooks will be
exchanged but it's much worse than that
black and our excuse me white could
actually crashed through on g7 and after
rook takes Knight the finishing move is
King to e5 and what can black do the
rook is attacked it's really running out
of squares if either one of these rooks
makes use of f8 whether it be this a8
rook to play to f8 to defend this rook
or the rook going back it leads to a
million two there's absolutely nothing
that can be done so in this position
after King to e5 black simply resigned
there's not a good solution to King
takes rook or this idea of giving
checkmate with the rooks playing to both
h7 and g7 so that's all for this video
as always I hope you got something out
of it take care bye
you